thing is riding on Starfield but I mean
that every week for the whole two
minutes
I feel I feel like they looked at me and
said how do we keep an idiot and
suspense
here here's my thing with it
good I I do feel like oh
give Microsoft that smoke they did make
they set expectations they uh they gave
you dates that you know realistically
they didn't know they could keep it or
not especially from like a third party
point of view but at the same time as
much as I overwhelmingly want the game
to come out more than I care about their
dates like I I want the game to come out
not broken then I care about their day
to come out the best thing to lie to you
and here's you like them to lie to you
no that's not the that's not the point I
care about the the health of of
Starfield and whether or not this game
comes out in